violaine des immunologistes membres du
collectif kovy 19 laissons les médecins
à prescrire bonsoir à violaines guérin
merci d'être avec nous en direct sur rt
france on vient d'entendre un moderne
therapeutics qui parle de résultats
encourageants on peut se poser la
question est ce vraiment le cas quand on
sait que seuls huit patients reçu deux
doses de vaccin ont développé des
anticorps neutralisants entre le virus
lors s'est-il huit patients le 18 mai
parce que j'avais entendu la
communication directe du directeur
général donc probablement que kylie a eu
plus de d'administration en revanche
l'étude de phase 1 effectivement semble
être très compressé les patients a
priori qui ont commencé à recevoir les
doses sont jeunes puisqu'ils ont entre
18 et 55 ans et il semblerait que le
laboratoire ait décidé de faire d'autres
administrations avec des personnes plus
âgées ce qui serait cohérent puisque on
veut en particulier de l'ordre des cas
de vaccination surtout sur un une
pathologie de type coronavirus protéger
des personnes âgées avec des comores
méditer donc on a l'impression
effectivement qu'on va un peu vite dans
tout cela c'est la constante qu'on
observe sur cette crise du cornât virus
il y à des enjeux financiers majeurs les
laboratoires et en particulier comme l'a
dit votre collègue
savent très bien manipulé en particulier
des réponses de biotech manipuler les
annonces pour faire bouger les cours de
bourse et c'est ce qui sous-tend ensuite
les investit des gros investissements
dont vous avez parlé
donc tout ça se questionne beaucoup
parce que effectivement normalement on
va plutôt communiquer quand on a des
résultats certains
comment justement vous expliquer ce côté
on va trop vite parce que c'est quand
même quelque chose qui est relayé
également par la presse on sait quel
point c'est très très long de trouver un
vaccin et là on l'on présente cela comme
une quasi solutions il y avait
énormément de laboratoires qui
travaillent sur le sujet et et on veut à
l'évidence est le premier à communiquer
parce qu'il ya toujours un effet
extrêmement positif d'être le premier à
faire émerger une solution thérapeutique
donc c'est un petit peu cela on
s'aperçoit dans l'historique de de ce
laboratoire qui a eu beaucoup de
communication comme ça en a qui sont
arrivés ils sont arrivés à lever
beaucoup de fonds avec genêt je n'ai pas
réussi à trouver exactement les produits
qu'ils ont finalement commercialisé avec
des autorisations de mise sur le marché
en tout cas il m'a pas sur le marché
français à ma connaissance et les
avances beaucoup en faisant ses
communications et ce quel prof des tld
des laboratoires de biotechnologies ou
ou de du domaine de des
télécommunications de light is et c'est
un peu comme ça qu'il est qu'ils y font
de nous avancer la communication vous
l'avez très bien expliqué c'est très
important mais on sait aussi voilà que
les agréments sont très difficiles à
avoir que c'est très long le dis tout le
temps les vaccins sont difficiles au
long il faut voilà les tester avoir les
autorisations pourquoi cela irait plus
vite cette fois ci selon vous parce
qu'il ya la pression de la pandémie
donc on se trouve dans des cas de
situation entre guillemets d'urgence
on peut avoir des procédures accélérées
mais ces procédures accélérées sont
souvent extrêmement dangereuse parce
qu'effectivement on va trop vite donc on
va trop vite sous plein de plans sous la
recherche de doses puisque là on
s'aperçoit qu'il ya eu trois doses
testées 25 100 et 250 microgrammes dans
ce qui a été communiqué en tout cas par
le laboratoire donc sondé recherche de
doses entre 500 et 250 qu'il y aurait
peut-être pu avoir d'autres pas dire est
un donc ça déjà c'est important à
prendre conscience on va souvent trop
vite et pourtant la recherche de dos
c'est quelque chose de crucial
et puis l évaluation des événements
indésirables de ce que j'ai pu le voir
dans ce qui a été communiqué par le
laboratoire sur la dose de 250
microgrammes il ya eu quand même pas mal
d'effets indésirables
donc là on en a pas parlé non plus donc
tout cela normalement prendre prend du
temps et c'est un petit peu choquant
puisque bon vous savez que moi je fais
partie du collectif laissons les
médecins prescrire et qui a tout à fait
conscience qu'il y a dans cette
pathologie des solutions thérapeutiques
même si on n'a pas voulu beaucoup en
parler donc c'est certain que les
vaccins sont intéressants mais on
devrait effectivement prendre tout le
temps de faire ce qu'on appelle un
développement correct
on a beaucoup parlé ensemble justement
de l'hydroxyde chloroquine ce soir les
etats-unis retirent l'autorisation
d'urgence de cette molécule pour le coc
vide
19 comment vous vous l'expliquer ce
petit rebondissement
on est très surpris de
2 comment la crise ce paf parce que il y
a à l'évidence des intérêts
pharmaceutiques à la fois sur les
vaccins comme on vient d'en parler mais
également sur des thérapeutiques
et puis il ya toujours cette
problématique du protocole hydroxy clan
qui n'hésiteront missile qui n'a pas été
très suivie à grande échelle dans une
phase précoce à part les publications
dont on a déjà parlé
et là il ya des enjeux un petit peu
curieux avec les états qui se
précipitent qui on a entendu parler de
la france qui a signé un investissement
pour un vaccin en partenariat avec
quatre pays européens alors qu'on essaye
de faire l'europe de la médecine
il ya plein de plein de précipitations
est plein d'enjeux je pense financiers
plus que totalement rationnelle et
scientifique et donc ont subi cela vous
verrez complexe beaucoup en tout cas on
aura compris cette complexité
surtout la prudence aussi vous affichez
merci violaine rien avoir été avec nous
en direct sur rt france merci à vous